so tick-tock is a very creative up now
that tick-tock stars are such a huge
part of our lives it's almost hard to
imagine a time without them but even the
biggest tick-tock influencers started
out as regular people just like us and
guess what
they still are check out these famous
tick tock stars who look completely
different in real life they're more
relatable than ever even though it might
seem like tick tock stars spend all of
their time flying from one tropical
destination to another in private planes
and raking in millions of dollars in
real life they're actually just normal
people like everyone else sure they
might be super famous and be painted
head to toe an amazing makeup but once
the makeup and the camera come off you
might not even be able to tell the
difference between them and anybody else
and some of them are totally different
than how they appear online so I wanted
to give you something that you could
always sort of relate back to and take
Kristen hunter for instance Kristen has
built up a massive following on
tick-tock and Instagram because of her
amazing makeup looks and the fact that
she totally looks like the lost
Kardashian sister she is one of the
biggest stars on the app with over 23
million followers on Tik Tok alone but
while you might think Kristen grew up in
a Beverly Hills mansion based off of the
way she looks
she actually has pretty humble
beginnings and when she logs off her
life returns to normal
Kristen is actually from Ontario Canada
and recently she has been forced to stay
back home in the house she grew up in
because of complications with her visa
she had to leave her friends her clothes
and even her dog behind at her home in
Los Angeles but we hope at least she
arranged for someone to feed her poor
pup before she moved to LA Kristen was
just another Canadian girl showing off
her makeup skills on YouTube that was
before she shaved her head - Kristen has
recently been sporting this super short
hairdo
but fans almost never get to see her
with her natural hair as she is always
sporting one of her beloved wigs it's
clear that she works really hard to
achieve her signature look so much so
that some people have even accused her
of getting plastic surgery or
experimenting with Photoshop in order to
change her face entirely do you think
Kristen has had plastic surgery let us
know in the comments below and be sure
to tell us
if you'd recognize her in real life
sometimes you need a break for makeup
with a name like Beast eater and a
tick-tock that is almost exclusively
filled with videos of her in a neon
green wig and creepy white contact
lenses it might be really hard to
imagine that the girl who goes by Beast
eater is actually just a regular person
with 7.3 million Tik Tok fans and
hundreds of thousands of both YouTube
and Instagram alike this funny crazy and
gorgeous viral star seems like she was
born to be famous but in reality she
started out just like anyone else her
name and real life is actually Stephanie
Margaret II she was born in Las Vegas
Nevada which might explain why she knows
how to put on an amazing show Stephanie
really seems like the kind of girl who
was all about going to the gym and
shopping for her amazing outfits but
when the cameras aren't rolling she
really just likes to curl up with her
boyfriend Marcus Olin and eat her
beloved pizza rolls you might think that
someone like Beast eater is rarely seen
without an awesome makeup look but if
you check out her earlier YouTube videos
she looks a whole lot more natural there
are also lots of old pictures out there
that show what she looked like before
tick tock became her full-time job with
her naturally brown hair and full
eyebrows while fans have been in the
comments to let her know that they think
she looks prettier without her green wig
we think she looks awesome no matter
what it just goes to show that even the
coolest makeup artists and tick tock
stars can't be on all the time either
way we're loving Stephanie's alter ego
on tick-tock Oh Sebastian Belle's has
got to be one of the wildest viral stars
out there with 10 million followers on
Tik Tok alone he is one of the busiest
content creators out there and
definitely the king of cringe Sebastian
has made it his trademark to have a
totally out there look where a ton of
makeup and get spray tans that even
Paris Hilton and Nicole Richie would
have considered too Orange even back in
the early days of the simple life but he
isn't trying to look natural in any way
he knows he looks the way he does and he
owns it 100% but that doesn't mean it
doesn't take work when Bailes is in
front of the camera he is putting on a
character but his action
very different from who he really is and
like any other character it starts with
the makeup he spends two hours every
morning getting his hair and makeup just
right before starting to film any of his
videos he also gets multiple rounds of
painful lip fillers in order to change
the shape of his lips entirely because
of all the mean comments he used to get
about them back in the day on top of all
that he bleaches his naturally brown
hair into his signature platinum blonde
regularly don't ever let anyone tell you
being a tick-tock star is easy
Lauren gray is another one of those
tick-tock stars who might seem too
perfect to be true but it's actually
totally different off camera than she is
on Lauren is one of the biggest stars on
tik-tok with over 46 million followers
she also has a massive following on
YouTube and Instagram alike making her a
massive viral sensation
she's almost never seen on tick-tock
without long hair extensions her winged
eyeliner and foss eyelashes and is
always in one cute outfit or another but
on YouTube she lets her viewers see a
whole other side of her but this is
unique to her videos that document her
morning routine or how she gets ready in
these videos she shares intimate details
about her everyday life including the
fact that sometimes her dog even leaves
her unwanted gifts in the morning you
she also includes facts about her life
like that she usually has yogurt and
granola for breakfast at home where she
lives with her mom and even though she
might already seem like she is set for
life she still had to graduate high
school which she did from home while she
could probably afford to hire an
assistant to do all the things that she
doesn't want to do herself Lauren's
day-to-day life isn't all that glamorous
and involves a ton of errands and other
pretty basic life activities so that's
the move gonna go out to movie
promised samang is a giant Internet star
in her own right with a YouTube channel
that features some of the best makeup
tutorials and cosplay transformations
out there and of course a ton of
followers on Tik Tok
but promise isn't one of those tick-tock
stars who found fame overnight she has
actually been creating makeup videos
since all the way back in 2012 while she
hasn't made it huge in North America she
was actually born in Nepal she comes
from very humble beginnings as both of
her parents are actually missionaries
who traveled around building churches in
villages all over the world even though
she is obviously very talented as an
artist she never did well in school
which led her down the path towards
creating her own content on YouTube she
loves her millions of fans now
especially since she was bullied a lot
in high school when her family moved to
America and she often had to eat lunch
by herself in the locker room even
though she looks like she is totally
perfect all the time
even promise immediately takes it all
off as soon as she gets home at the end
of the day instead of lounging around in
a glamorous robe or pajamas set she
would rather just chill out in the
shorts and a t-shirt we can totally
relate to that how long have you been
following promised on social media tell
us in the comments I feel like just
being different and just being
while most of us just think about how
tick tock stars present themselves
online we never really imagine how weird
it must be to be that famous and still
have to do normal things you know go to
school or hang out at the mall with
friends it might seem like it would be
awesome to be the most famous kid in
your high school but for tick tock star
Haley sharp it's not easy at all even
though she is famous enough to do
glamorous things like appearing in a
dojo cat music video she actually lives
a really normal life when tick-tock
teens first start going viral with their
videos some parents decide that the best
thing to do is to pull them out of
school and homeschool them so they can
focus as much as possible on their super
lucrative new careers and since Haley
has over a million followers on the app
you might think her parents would have
done the same but in reality Haley still
goes to school like everyone else
even if she is followed by most of her
classmates not only that but her parents
still make her get summer jobs like most
kids we know which made it a little
awkward when she started getting
recognized by customers she served at
the ice cream store she worked at and
maybe go to college out here after I
graduate high school some tick tock
stars out there have made it big by
being totally original and others like
vampy Jordan have decided to go a
different route Bambi Jordan has gained
hundreds of thousands of followers on
tick tock by impersonating Captain Jack
Sparrow himself Johnny Depp and while it
might seem like he is Donnie's long-lost
twin he is actually nothing like the
famous actor in real life for starters
he's British he lives in Wales in the
United Kingdom with his mom and is an
aspiring actor and even though you'd
think that the job offers for a man who
looks so much like Johnny Depp would
never stop rolling in he actually only
has one unpaid acting credit to his name
but that doesn't mean he isn't going to
keep trying and as long as his tik-tok
fans are happy he's clearly doing
something right well there you go even
the biggest tick tock stars with their
hundreds of millions of likes and
followers still have normal lives to
live some of them are so different off
camera it's hard to believe it's really
them who is your favorite tick tock star
is there someone you really wish you
could meet in real life let us know in
the comments also
covering little loose back we hope you
liked this video as much as we liked
making it for you don't forget to hit
that subscribe button while you're here
to keep up with all of the best videos
from the things thanks for watching
[Music]